et dernier entraînement avant le jour j
pour caroline jouissent et marcel
schouten le duo franco néerlandais en
couple hors des bassins pendra d'ici
quelques heures la direction de jablines
en seine-et-marne pour les championnats
de france de libre une compétition de
nage en milieu naturel cette année dans
un étang pas toujours simple lorsque
l'on s'entraîne régulièrement à la
piscine les virages évidemment c'est pas
du tout comme sur une ligne droite puis
il faut aussi parvenir à se frayer un
chemin parmi la meute de nageurs c'est
ce qui rend la tâche plus difficile pour
ceux qui sont habitués à nager en ligne
parce que là et bien fausse créer son
propre couloir
parmi les épreuves de la compétition
un relais mixte 4 fois 1250 mètres et
des courses individuelles sur 5 10 et
même 25 km alors oui ça peut être long
mais pas inintéressant pour autant
je le compare souvent au cyclisme parce
que c'est un effort qui peut être très
très long mais qui peut ce qui la
plupart du temps se termine au sprint
par exemple un 25 km le podium peut
jouer à deux secondes la première peut
être caroline quand elle avait fait un
podium il ya quatre ans elle avait fini
troisième à deux secondes de la première
alors que c'est alors que ça dure cinq
heures et demie ont nagé près de cinq
heures une épreuve physique qui peut
être éprouvante
les participants peuvent donc bénéficier
de ravitaillement pendant l'épreuve un
moment plus stratégique qu'il n'y paraît
bah ça peut faire l'écart en fait c'est
à ce moment là où souvent un paquet aura
tendance à exploser
parce que certaines prendront leur
ravitaillement très vite et partiront
donc le sautron et du coup ça peut faire
exploser un paquet en fait c'est au
ravitaillement de sattouf ou très
souvent ou alors au passage
début de la compétition ce vendredi pour
nos deux nageurs qui compte bien revenir
à bourges avec une médaille autour du
cou